coffee date anyone yes kim kardashian
was spotted meeting with hillary clinton
and her daughter chelsea at the hot and
cool cafe in canoga park california
where they were seen with a camera crew
i have so many exciting things coming
out kim rocked a shiny black trench coat
lime green thigh-high boots and a pair
of black sunglasses while hillary opted
for one of her signature pantsuits in
gray with the black blouse chelsea is
seen coordinating with her mom wearing a
black sweater and charcoal skirt it's a
great look the powerhouse trio was
reportedly filming for a new clinton-led
docu-series for apple tv
titled gutsy women inspired by hillary
and chelsea's best-selling novel
the book of gutsy women favorite stories
of courage and resilience the
docu-series they are filming is said to
feature a diverse cast of trail-blazing
women and it looks as if kim fits the
bill so far the skim's founder has built
her own beauty empire and used her
platform to enact change advocating for
prison reform over the last few years i
just think that
you know where i'm at in my life now if
i can influence people in other ways
and just to take something that's close
to their heart and use their platform to
speak up
that's what's really important to me
last month kim revealed she passed the
baby bar exam sharing these photos of
her donning a chic blue dress
captioning it quote i passed the baby
bar exam
looking in the mirror i am really proud
of the woman looking back today in the
reflection she went on to share quote i
failed this exam three times in two
years but i got back up each time and
studied harder and tried again until i
did it i did have covet on the third try
with a 104 fever but i'm not making any
excuses i learned from seeing both of my
parents work really hard becoming a
lawyer is something kim has been
striving for since 2018 but instead of
going to a traditional law school the 41
year old is taking california's
alternative route she explained quote in
california the way i'm studying law you
need to take two bar exams this was just
the first one but with the harder pass
rate adding quote i was told by top
lawyers that this was a close to
impossible journey and harder than the
traditional law school route but it was
my only option and it feels so so so
good to be here and on my way to
achieving my goals i've always
hoped that it would be a big
empire as you said not me
aside from social justice reform kim
publicly endorsed hillary clinton in the
2016 presidential election when she was
running against donald trump
writing in an essay on her former app
quote without a doubt i stand with
hillary i'm with her this year i'm not
just voting for myself but also for my
children and i took that into careful
consideration when i made my decision
[Music]